Die mondlandung am 20 juli 1967 auch heute wohl immer noch einer der größten momente der menschheitsgeschichte
Der man on the moon und millionen von menschen haben mitgefiebert. Und der reiz ist nicht
Kleiner geworden wir berichten hier immer wieder über pläne demnächst mal wieder auf dem mond
Zu landen doch wie ist die mondlandung damals wirklich. Abgelaufen was ist von den verschwörungstheorien
Zu halten nachdem die mondlandung niemals stattgefunden hat. Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
Und den anderen messen gewünschten bekommt jetzt die fünf. Spannendsten facts der mondlandung herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
Vorab noch etwas zu den messengern die abo boxee auf youtube.de ist ja schlimm. Ihr habt einfach
Keine möglichkeit sicherzustellen dass sie eher fad wenn. Ein
neues video online geht deshalb meine bitte
In meinem vor allem aber auch in eurem interesse folgten mehr auf whatsapp. Und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst. Ihr garantiert kein video
Mehr und jetzt könnt ihr euch übrigens da auch. Über einen disco server miteinander verknüpfen
Auf der 5 darum sind keine sterne auf den bildern der mondlandung zu sehen
War die mondlandung echt oder war alles nur inszeniert. Ihr wisst wahrscheinlich alle dass sich. Um kaum ein thema mehr
Verschwörungstheorien ranken als um die mondlandung von 1969
Demnach ist die apollo-11-mission nie dort. Oben auf dem mond gewesen stattdessen hat die nasa alles in einem großen filmstudio
inszeniert einer der beweise dafür auf den bildern der mondlandung sind keine sterne zu sehen ja zudem
Weht die amerikanische flagge. Dabei gibt es doch gar
Kein wind auf dem mond und doch wahrscheinlich ja alles schon für dieses angebliche für diese angeblichen beweise gibt es wissenschaftliche
erklärungen auf den aufnahmen sind zum beispiel
keine sterne zu sehen weil die sonneneinstrahlung
Die mondoberfläche und die astronauten sehr hell erscheinen lässt die sterne leuchten dagegen nur
Schwach damit aber die astronauten auf dem bild auftauchen ist eine sehr kurze belichtungszeit
Nötig mit der sich das leuchten der sterne nicht mehr einfangen lässt auch auf den
meisten anderen
Fotos aus dem all sind die sterne ja meistens aus diesem grund nicht zu sehen und hier auf der erde sind ja übrigens tagsüber auch
Keine sterne zu sehen es ist einfach zu helfen. Und auch das wesen der flagge hat einen grund natürlich
Gleich die montur atmosphäre einem vakuum dort oben geht kein einziges münchen doch die flagge wird von neil armstrong
In den boden gerammt und durch diese erschütterung bewegt sich die flagge dort. Oben das hört
Aber nach einiger zeit auf und die flagge bleibt still auf der vier armstrongs fußabdruck auf dem mond bleibt
Wohl ewig der fußabdruck von neil armstrong ist wohl das symbol schlechthin für die erste mondlandung
Zitat nur ein kleiner schritt für einen menschen aber. Ein großer sprung für die menschheit
Das hat, er, gesagt auf englisch als er auf der ersten sprosse der leiter stand
Um aus dem lande modul namens igel als erster mensch auf die mondoberfläche
hinabzusteigen den armstrong ist längst tot doch seit fußabdruck
Wohl für die ewigkeit auf dem mond denn dort gibt es wie gesagt kein wind durch den
Er verwehrt werden könnte es gibt. Kein wetter. Keine witterung nichts was den fußabdruck auslöschen könnte höchstens
Einen asteroiden oder meteoriten anschlag könnte den. Abdruck zerstört auf der 3 die mondlandung war wirklich
ein absolut riesiges medienspektakel
die drei astronauten an bord der raumfähre columbia
Wurden durch ihre. Reise zum mond, zu weltweiten stars monatelang hatte
Ihr training für die reise ins all gedauert noch in den drei tagen der
Reise selbst hatten sie kaum etwas, zu tun auf den rund 380.000 kilometern zum mond hatten sie hauptsächlich fernseh interviews
Zu geben der auf der erde verfolgte wohl die gesamte menschheit das schicksal von neil armstrong. Michael collins. Und edwin aldrin
das waren wirklich krasse einsatz wurden damals denn
Soviel fernsehgeräte gab es noch nicht rund 600 millionen menschen oder aushalte verfolgten jedes detail
Am fernseher als sie drei helden wieder sicher auf der erde gelandet waren. Mussten sie, zunächst übrigens, drei wochen in quarantäne
Um, keine krankheiten vom mond einzuschleppen man wusste ja nicht ob und was dort
Oben hätte sein können, um, gehen lieber auf nummer sicher danach wurden sie bei einer großen parade in new york
Gefeiert auf der 2 ein wirkliches. Fun fact zurück wie müll
Und andere, umweltsünden nach 22 stunden aufenthalt verließ die igel wieder den mond doch die untere
Hälfte der startrampe ließ das team zurück an ihr befestigt eine plakette mit dem schriftzug hier setzten menschen vom planeten erde im juli
anno domini
Ihren fuß auf den mond wir kamen in frieden für die menschheit unterschrieben
hatten dass der amerikanische präsident richard nixon und die drei astronauten aber das war nicht das einzige
Was das team als andenken auf dem mond zurück ließ auch. Ihre, moonboots lehre essenspakete
Und volle urinbeutel ließen sie zurück das gewicht hätte gegebenenfalls den. Start der igel gefährden können
und auf der einst die nasa waren vor
Zunehmendem verkehr auf dem mond das ist wirklich verrückt es gibt. Immer mehr pläne schon
zeitnah wieder auf dem mond zu landen
Unter anderem ja auch von ihnen maske und genau das macht der nasa sorgen und so hat die us raumfahrtbehörde
Eine art verhaltens regelwerk aufgestellt. Und zwar nicht dass etwas. Passieren könnte befürchten sie, sondern nasa geht es. Um die
bodendenkmalpflege
Ja hier auf der erde sind dafür archäologen zuständig der werden dörfer von menschen. Ausgegraben römische villen und relikte aus urzeiten
Sowas auf dem mond ja auf 93 seiten geht es. Darum wie man. Apollo relikte
Und landesstellen auf dem mond schützen kann denn durch die vielen raumschiffe die in den nächsten. Jahren zum mond reisen wollen
könnten die messinstrumente
Rover landeplätze und fahnen leiten das ganze soll also für die nachwelt erhalten bleiben zudem fordert die nasa auch auf den mond als
Naturpark oder historische stätte zu schützen gut dass es kein. Unesco. Ehrt kultur erbe gibt sondern das
Weltkulturerbe da könnten dann auch. Die. Apollo landeplätze auf dem mond. So benannt werden ja wenn
ihr kein video zu den neuen plänen zur besiedlung des mondes
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube ist ja immer ziemlich
Lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt. Ihr von mir auch vor allen. Anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media hier abonnieren da erfahrt. Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter. Dafür auch drauf dicken menschen sollen auf dem mond siedeln bis. Dann
bleibt dran